[Music]
hi thank you so much for having me here
such a cool way of getting people from
different disciplines especially I'm
from social sciences to kind of talk
about very important issues facing our
society and how we can use
interdisciplinary methods to kind of
mitigate those issues so just a little
background on me before I start my
presentation so as I said earlier my
name is anamika berman Adhikari and i'm
an assistant professor in the School of
Social Work at the University of Denver
and in terms of my research interest I'm
fascinated with the idea of social
influence and for the last eight years I
have been trying to understand kind of
why people cluster in social networks
both face-to-face and online and kind of
the psychological sociological cognitive
and mathematical rules that govern how
these networks tend to operate in terms
of my talk today I have to add one
caveat before I even get into the
presentation I am NOT an AI expert I'm a
social scientist who has come to value
and appreciate how a I can be used in
the public health domain and I'm gonna
use one of our projects which is known
as guide to kind of showcase how
interdisciplinary research especially AI
and Public Health and Social Work can
come together to solve a very important
issue
in the domain of behavioral sciences and
especially substance abuse prevention ah
so as I said earlier we're gonna talk
about guide which is an acronym which
stands for group based intervention
decision aid for substance abuse
prevention among homeless youth but
before I get into that I think it would
be useful to get a sense of the scope of
substance abuse and homelessness among
you to experience homelessness in the
United States so in terms of the
population and numbers approximately 1.5
million youth are homeless in the u.s.
at any given point of the year which
might be surprising to a lot of you here
because the u.s. is one of the richest
countries in the world but we still have
stark levels of inequality
in terms of their rates of substance use
among homeless youth there are so many
things that plagued youth who experience
homelessness but substance abuse is
especially problem problematic so based
on data collected in between 2011 to
2013 in Los Angeles from thousand
homeless youth what we found is that
about a quarter of youth engage in
either recent in either meth use or
prescription drug misuse and about 15
percent 13 to 15 percent engage in
heroin or injection drug use and to put
these numbers into context why this is
problematic approximately 1 percent of
youth equivalently age to youth in the
u.s. who are housed and not homeless you
know engage in the same kind of drug use
rate so 1 percent versus 25 percent
that's pretty stark so one of the
reasons why I'm so interested in
substance abuse is because it is a
network-based phenomenon so social
influence is key to understanding why
people engage in drug abuse so this is a
network map and what you see here is 160
homeless youth who are connected to each
other in a social space and the blued
that note the blue dots are people like
all of the dots are people and the lines
are basically the relationships among
them and the blue nodes are people who
engage youth who engage in drug use and
the gray and white dots are people who
don't engage in drug use and what you
see here is that really drug use is a
public health phenomenon right all the
drug users tend to be + tend to cluster
together which is explained by classic
social science theories homophily the
notion that birds of the same feather
flock together and also social learning
theory if you're around people who
engage in a behavior guess what you're
more likely to engage in that behavior
so however the ironic thing is that in
terms of preventing drug use
even though networks are implicated in
how why substance abuse happens networks
are also the key to preventing drug
abuse so what research has found that
prevention programs are most effective
and they have a peer component because
then people get to exit you know engage
in drug refusal skills or drug resistant
skills in their natural peer environment
so the way these peer network
interventions have been designed is that
people are usually assigned to groups
based on random assignment without any
knowledge of how they're connecting to
their peers or also you know not an
understanding of the social space where
where they're engaging in drug use or
the other method that is used is that
you get to choose their own peer groups
and if you go back to the previous slide
what we saw is that peers tend to hang
out with other peers who are like
themselves so well a lot of times what
happens is that a lot of users come to
you know get together and that increases
their drug use behavior which is known
by this term called deviancy training
and deviancy training is a problem in
prevention sighs science it has been a
sticky problem in prevention science
ever since we have been trying to
prevent drug abuse among any groups of
youth so in terms of the question we
wanted to address or the problem you
wanted to address through our
interdisciplinary collaboration is how
to assign people to groups based on
their existing network relationships and
also their substance use behaviors and
the way we saw how a I helped is that
within with AI we wanted to understand
whether we could have a predictive
algorithm that could tell us whether or
not if we engage in that intervention if
deviancy training would be exacerbated
or if it could reduce deviancy training
so in the context of AI we really saw
this is as a graph partitioning problem
so if you go back you know to the figure
that I showed you earlier how what if we
could design an algorithm that could
reconfigure this network based on you
know drug use and as well as
pre-existing relationships in a way
where we could optimize positive
influence so instead of like cutting
these networks into
clusters we had to reconfigure people in
in a way that we could basically reduce
the problem of deviancy training so in
order to do that we thought we had to
model three important parameters and I'm
gonna talk about what parameters were
included and not really the simulation
techniques and Phoebe's gonna address
that in her talk but in terms of
understanding why deviancy training
happens and how to mitigate it we
thought there are three important
modeling components that we needed to
include in our algorithm first is
network influence which I'm going to
talk about the second is network dynamic
modeling and third is interventionist
modeling so in terms of influence
modeling as amelia was saying earlier
there are competing influences in
networks there people are associated
with a lot of people and because of the
diversity of these influences they're
both positive and negative influences on
people so the way we saw it is that it
is a linear threshold model so basically
people get you know both positive and
negative influences from their peers and
if the influence signal crosses the
threshold value then the person is more
likely to change their behavior so for
example if a user is connected to more
non users then users they're more likely
to change their behavior also because
this intervention the way we design
social work interventions is that it
happens over a period of time and over
that period of time people change their
behaviors and also their relationships
it was important for us to model how
those relationships change and the what
we hypothesize is that if a user became
a non user they are probably more likely
to strengthen their relationships with
other non users and weaken their
relationships with other users and
that's something we also wanted to model
in the algorithm also there is the
interventionist component so in social
work usually interventions are delivered
by professionals and they are also a key
component of the intervention
and we wanted to basically understand
what kind of relationships the
participants have with the
interventionist and how that changes the
nature of their behaviors as well as
their networks in terms of the results
what we found is that Guy'd outperforms
the traditional status quo methods of
random assignment and peer chosen groups
by almost 40% that's pretty huge and
that's statistically and practically
meaningful and what this emphasizes is
that you know it's important to
acknowledge existing relationships and
network tie strengths and behavior in
understanding how we can minimize
deviancy training how guide helps in the
real world we are planning to deploy
this decision aid in a shelter in Denver
Calera
Colorado and what we'll be able to do is
to predict scenarios where deviancy
training is increased does you know
saving time money and effort future
strategies real-world deployment that I
talked about we also need to make
certain tweaks to our model to kind of
include uncertainties and we also need
to make our model a little more complex
because right now we are just modeling
three things we hope to model other
behavioral parameters that might also
and demographic variables that might
also impact substance abuse so that
concludes my presentation I'll be happy
to talk to you later or answer any
questions you have right now thank you
[Applause]
so that's a great question
so substance abuse happens prior to
people becoming homeless and it could be
a cause of homelessness as well so a lot
of people become homeless because their
substance users and also because they
have to exist you know survive in an
environment where drug abuse is
considered to be a survival skill it
could get as exacerbated because of the
circumstances they face after the
experience homelessness
it could be bought it's the chicken and
egg thing